je vous fais une petite sonnerie
l'attaquent l'attaquent
je crois que je sonne la taille de
france à mon grand père parce que mon
grand-père a rendu son dernier souffle
en espérons sur le champ de bataille
ces groupes là ils sont l attaque est
l'ennemi a craqué alors il a pris un
boulet dans le pavillon il a avalé
l'embouchure ça pardonne pas alors quand
on a rapporté son clairon à sa veuve
elle a dit oui quelle idée aussi d'aller
faire de la musique dans un moment
pareil je ne se rendait pas compte
alors mon père a repris le flambeau mais
flambeau parce que nous sommes tous
clairon de père en fils et mon père a
fait toutes les guerres en tant que les
rangs d'ailleurs pour mon père la guerre
c'était une belle sonnerie il les a tout
fait
il a sonné toutes les attaques de la
guerre 14-18 et toutes les retraites de
la guerre 39 40
et les morts à la retraite d'une attaque
dans son lit dont le destin il faut pas
se tromper de sonneries parce que la
sonnerie et sonneries bon exemple
ouvrez le ban fermez le ban c'est la
même chose alors le soldat qui n'a pas
retenu qu on ouvrait le banc quand on
fait un micro à comps louvre
il attend conscient alors quand on ouvre
un nouveau tu crois que c'est la
fermeture des grandes chez lui c'est
comme ça qu'on vers les guerres jettera
d'ailleurs le client pardonnez moi
l'expression et sont tous un peu sonné
moi mon voisin c'est mon professeur de
clairon en plus déjà pendant la guerre
il était porte drapeau il a tellement
pris l'habitude de brandir un drapeau
que depuis qu'il a peut-être drapeau il
brandit plus dit il et b style com parce
que non qui m'ont dit plus il émettait
alors quelques fois j'entends sa femme
qui a eu bris qui lui écrivent les
brandit autre chose
non c'est un drapeau rien elle écrit
accroche un drap blanc ou d'un manche à
balai et bondouy capituler le ramène
puis l'entente parce qu'ils jouent il
apprend d'oreille
alors quand il quand ils veulent une
leçon quand ils jouent ça donne ça
arrive dit voulez-vous me prêter une
oreille attentive parce qu'il paraît
quand on prête l'oreille on entend mieux
enfin c'est le font c'est faux il m'est
arrivé de prêter l'oreille d'un sourd il
entendait pas bien parce que vous avez
les phrases toutes faites comme ça
allait frappe j'ai ouï dire qu'ils
avaient des choses qui est entré par une
oreille et ressorti par l'eau non mais
franchement je n'ai jamais rien vu entré
par une oreille et encore moins à en
sortir il ya qu'en littérature cours
sera évidemment dans rabelais dans
rabelais nous lisons que car gamelle
amilcar quand tu as au monde parlant et
gauche parce qu'il sous-entend que par
l'oreille droite
il veut se passer des choses du temps
des grilles et des sucettes pas de quoi
vous faire dresser l'oreille alors le
verrou ir en présence a fait jour jours
ci au lieu de dire j'entends jeu du jour
les gens vont penser que ce que
j'entends et jouer eu alors que ce que
j'entends peut être particulièrement
triste
il faudrait préciser n'est ce pas dieu
que ce que joie et triste
joie que tu vois mon chien qui aboie le
soir au fond des bois juillet il doit
ses bêtes loi mois el ouali ce que nous
allions loi loi tel sérieux de dire le
rayon dit louis louis de loi oui pour
peu que l'on appartienne à louis alors
là louis de louis a oui ah oui
et karoui louis de loi de louis alaoui
ce que tous trois mois et quoi toutefois
elle n'a toutefois avoir commencé à
boire le soir au fond des bois toutefois
avoir whaou ont passé ça fait jouit joue
il ya vraiment pas quoi